- [Voiceover] Hi everyone.
Here and in the next few videos
I'm gonna be talking about
tangent planes of graphs,
and I'll specify this is
tangent planes of graphs
and not of some other thing
because in different context
of multivariable calculus you
might be taking a tangent plane
of say a parametric surface
or something like that but here
I'm just focused on graphs.
In the single variable
world a common problem that
people like to ask in calculus
is you have some sort of
curve and you wanna find at a
given point what the tangent
line to that curve is,
where the tangent line is.
You’ll find the equation
for that tangent line
and this gives you various
information how to,
let's say you wanted to approximate
the function around that
point and it turns out to be
a nice simple approximation.
In the multivariable world
it's actually pretty similar
in terms of geometric intuition
it's almost identical.
You have some kind of graph of a function,
like the one that I have
here, and then instead of
having a tangent line,
because the line is a very
one-dimensional thing and here
it's a very two-dimensional
surface, instead you’ll have
some kind of tangent plane.
This is something where it's
just gonna be barely kissing
the graph in the same way
that the tangent line just
barely kisses the function
graph in the one-dimensional
circumstance, and it could be
at various different points
rather than just being at that point.
You could move it around and
say that it will just barely be
kissing the graph of this
function but at different points.
Usually the way that a problem
like this will be framed
if you're trying to find such
a tangent plane is first,
you think about the specified
input that you want.
In the same way that over
in the single variable world
what you might do is say,
"What is the input value here?"
Maybe you'd name it like x
sub 0, and then you're gonna
find the graph of the
function that corresponds to
just kissing the graph
at that input point.
Over here in the multivariable
world, move things about,
you'll choose some input
point like this little red dot
and that could be at
various different spots,
it doesn’t have to be where I put it,
you could imagine putting
it somewhere else.
Once you decide on what
input point you want,
you see where that is on the graph,
so we go and say, "That
input point corresponds to
such and such a height,"
so in this case it actually
looks like the graph is
about zero at that point
so the output of the
function would be zero.
What you want is the plane
that's tangent right at that point.
You’ll draw some kind of plane that's
tangent right at that point.
If we think about what this
inner point corresponds to
it's not x sub 0, a single variable input
like we have in the single variable world,
but instead that red dot
that you're seeing is gonna
correspond to some kind of
input here, x sub 0, y sub 0.
The ultimate goal over
here in our multivariable
circumstance is gonna be to
find some kind of new function,
so I'll write it down here,
some kind of new function
that I'll call L, for linear,
that's gonna take in x and y,
and we want the graph of that
function to be this plane,
and you might specify that this
is depended on the original
function that you have and
maybe also specify that it's
depended on this input point
in some way, but the basic idea
is we're gonna be looking
for a function whose graph
is this plane tangent at a given point.
In the next couple of videos
I'm gonna talk through
how you actually compute that.
It might seem a little intimidating
at first because how do
you control a plane in
three dimensions like this?
It's actually very similar
to the single variable
circumstance, and you just
take it one step at a time.
See you in next video.